Is PEMF therapy okay if one has a seizure disorder? Okay, we were talking about PEMF therapy
And it's a great therapy, but there are some drawbacks
So you can't use PEMF therapy if you have an electrical device implanted like
pacemaker
You can't use PEMF therapy if you have a seizure disorder
Well, you could if you didn't let's say on your feet or
Or something like that, but you'd have to be really careful
So there's some things you can't do use PEMF therapy for because it's an electrical therapy
So whereas the right is light frequencies of PEMF therapy is an electrical therapy
And it could throw up a pacemaker or something like that. So no, I wouldn't use it if I had a seizure disorder